[Music]
swipe left if you're under six feet no
tattoo chicks yup if you don't work out
we won't work out no rice no spice white
guys only please be hot so this is
messed up right right but everyone seems
to go along with it but would they if
someone did this in the real world
everybody has these filters and these
barrier that they have in their mind
they want or won't do right so whenever
you do it you just do it automatically
yeah you just go in there air fat guy oh
this oh no I don't like beers
oh there's Nepalese hot and then you
select that person to chill whenever
you're in the market oh yeah
split-second decisions or what we do
every day it's part of stuff I happen
you do that for love you do that for
work we come to conclusions about people
within the first three second people are
not gonna walk you I'm not gonna talk to
you because you have a beard and then
leave that's not just not gonna talk to
you but it's just business meant to be
fat look I haven't seen this but I could
already tell just based off how cool it
is these people think they're gonna make
a good point yes and it's gonna be weird
just by the how corny the intro was
absolutely what if Natasha we're to
swipe right on hundreds of guys invite
them all on a date and treat them just
like we've been treating each other on
tinder what would people say wait we're
gonna invite him live see you're not
making a point you're just being
dishonest not only you're wasting
people's time but you are lying to them
you are come down thin with the pretense
that you may potentially interested meet
up with them and then actually embarrass
them on camera I'm done so I've quickly
realized holding conversations with all
these guys just isn't gonna work just
too many of them so I've developed a
system step 1 we message with a guy on
tinder and give him a Twilio phone
number step 2 this programmable phone
number is routed through an online
database this central hub can send and
receive texts and be logged into from
anywhere in the world leading us to step
3 farming out this texting operation to
overseas workers over 50 full-time
workers help us to text with guys
converting a tinder match
to a tender date and if you were to call
any of our numbers they forward to this
phone with a voicemail so I need a
meeting location for Natasha and all
these guys that's why I've created a
fake EDM event complete with stage sound
and our friend Nick AM guys will be told
to stand next to the stage and after she
says hi to her DJ friend they'll go off
on their date
I'll never expect a thing
[Music]
with the bodyguards oh that's too much
too much Stiles hey - massage - massage
a limo too much sauce tumor starts Nick
am to myself too much sauce to miss our
bodies to ourselves - to myself that's
to myself yo I think Oh [ __ ] I think
this is the kind of [ __ ] that makes me
hate [ __ ] cuz if this is me I'm either
leaving or I'm throwing Tomatoes too
much yeah who's about to you weigh more
sauce with my tomatoes on stage yeah if
I'm supposed to meet up with you with on
one-on-one date and this turns out to be
a gimmick [ __ ] I'm gone I've got too
much self-respect to waste my [ __ ]
time listen to you on stage this is the
most self-serving garbage I've ever seen
this way their face their faith he's
like oh yeah no he's like [ __ ] wet like
I'm leaving he's like I've had that
she's like please
dating apps are very difficult and I
said maybe I can bring everyone here in
person and see how that goes so do you
have what it takes to win a date with me
[Applause]
here's the worst part about this like as
people are just taking this like a bad
prank or anything like that think about
the guy who finally lands his first date
on tinder and finds out it turns out to
be this gimmicky garbage you know like
going on dates is already stressful
enough for people you know rejection is
hard enough as it is to do this in such
a [ __ ] scandalous way to me means
your trash human being and the fact you
don't have to empathy that realize that
someone may suffer from this kind of
event means to me you're trash when it
comes to matters of the heart and when
it comes to intimacy and love and [ __ ]
like that when it comes to rejection I
always tell we gotta you got to be
compassionate for the person that you
are leaving because you know if you go
unnecessarily cruel on them you are
putting trauma that the next person is
gonna have to deal with in it's just
like don't it's [ __ ] with trench
whack gonna start the elimination half
of you people here are in relationships
so those people should leave now anyone
under 510 please leave as well no beer
bellies no long beards no bald guys no
khakis or is any less than six inches
you know you gotta go
also anyone named Jimmy I don't enjoy
the name Jimmy ready one
[Music]
the worst bro I hated this girl from the
top where did you get this I hated this
girl from the top now I hate everything
who got up down there to do push-ups for
this listen guys out there who will do
anything for a [ __ ]
I want to spit in your faces as rare as
I say things with anger in my heart but
he's the one of the few things like like
you guys are pathetic to me mmm like
guys who can't say no to a girl's
demands especially an average girl like
this who's this self-serving and this
much of a piece of [ __ ] and you still
get down there to do push-ups like some
[ __ ] monkey right just cuz you want
to get your dick wet have some goddamn
standards have some goddamn standards
oh the guys out lined up yo this is hard
but then again but then again you know
what you bet again you know what the
point that she was trying to prove is
that you acting like tinder in real life
is exactly how you feel
so what they're trying to works cuz what
they try to prove was that it was this
it was this what if the premise of this
was what if people acted as gender in
real life so she's not trash she's being
she's doing exactly what she said she
would do which is talking to people like
they were alive on tinder she's problems
go ahead premise one the first problem
they didn't come here under the pretense
I'm gonna have yeah so there's no faxes
no chat second problem is that this is
happening public in front of everybody
else so me coming to reject to one on
one is one could be making a spectacle
and lining everybody up and be like hey
I'm not interested in you not interested
in you because she's not a big-ass mic
yeah that's a different thing different
thing this why I was talking about the
compassion to reject people respectful
yeah it's nothing wrong with saying no
to somebody in fact st. when you feel it
in your own matches one thing getting on
mass in front of a microphone and with
everybody looking at the mother said she
got referees yo too much sauce too much
bull you already as bad as a with too
much sauce
so you see that right she made that
smartass comment and was super ruin
people laughing you can tell this [ __ ]
heart day hurts and I only mentioned
this stuff and I will we care about the
suckers I know people don't give a [ __ ]
and so whenever I talked about this we
were like oh really it's like that I'm
like yelling people don't recognize with
dudes go through when it comes to this
[ __ ] and so they think it's funny just
because someone doesn't check off every
box on what we find attractive doesn't
mean they aren't it's absurd isn't it to
judge people by such petty things as if
they like to wear khakis
we know that look at how angry this
makes people and yet this is what we've
been doing the whole time I guess
sometimes you just have to lay a trap to
catch people's attention and start a
conversation
[Music]
online dating and its merits are
debatable okay the idea that it's
inherently negative because it makes
people superficial people are inherently
superficial to begin with you know maybe
I get to know you deeper afterwards
meeting you in person but off the top
when we go to clubs we're already
sifting through people and we're swiping
them in our heads to create an
application that facilitates that puts
us in touch I hate when people only talk
about the downsides of online tape you
know for the upsides you get to meet
people who are completely outside of
your social circle people you would
never meet face-to-face you get to see
them because they're because they're
five kilometres away or because even if
they're within 40 kilos
we would never cuz I don't want the same
clubs as them I have my circles I have
my spots and that's where I go to you
know what about for people who have
approach anxiety who find that approach
and women is terribly frightening
because they might deal with a [ __ ]
like you
right like what about what about guys
like that now they have a means to talk
to other women through means that you
know they don't have to be treated like
garbage in front of other human beings
because you don't have to approach
somebody in industry or in a club and
have to deal with that rejection so I
find it very ironic that a woman's like
I let's get rid of this [ __ ]
just approach this man you don't have to
approach it you don't have to put
yourself esteem online so maybe you
should shut the [ __ ] up and stay in your
lane cuz you're not gonna approach
you're now gonna approach the data in
the dating game women don't approach huh
you know what percent yeah but I do you
don't like your minimum you're a tiny
bit of this equation women don't
approach man to a man deal with
rejection that's why women have a hard
time dealing with rejection because they
don't have to deal it on a day-to-day
basis excuse me miss yeah like really
really really yeah you don't get to deal
with that you don't so it's a bit unfair
to be like to be like yeah no we want to
get a pro see stuff like that nah nah
you want to get approached you can't you
can't want feminism and everybody to be
alright and here I want people to
approach you okay you choose either want
it or you don't you want everybody to be
equal so you do the approaching two and
you take some of these Elle's
okay or
you just go back and do our thing cuz
the approaching thing women don't
approach man they don't they don't and
that's the stats whether you do you do
personally you're you're a minority oh
oh my Norah T of like not a lot of
people think it's I don't know what the
numbers on that but that's a man already
a woman approaching man but you know
listen 20% of marriages are happening
through people who met through online
dating so obviously it's working for a
lot of people this idea that you can't
build into men strong bonds with people
online is untrue sure it might start
with a superficial aspect but I think we
all need to feel a strong physical
attraction to someone before we feel
like we can perform a strong bond with
them or we would like that in our
relationships and the fact that people
seek that out as a base mandatory isn't
the worst thing in the world now if you
don't like it don't like it but don't
put out the pseudo-intellectual prank or
you waste men's time and you treat them
like garbage on camera and you do all
these stuff to make a point that's
involved because all you do is made
yourself look like an ass and so the
guys who participate in this knowing
what the [ __ ] this charade was you also
trashman yell get your standards up
[ __ ] because the moment you do this
whole game with the women is gonna be a
lot easier too much sauce to myself
three myself
[Music]
[Applause]